mcgruber is coming to peacock people
america's ultimate hero is back to save
the world
one throat rip at a time
[Laughter]
and you have to stream magruber right
now based on the cult favorite movie and
the iconic snl sketch only on peacock go
to peacocktv.com
to sign up and the man who's making all
of our mcgruber dreams come true
right here on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line one of our favorites will
forte back on the rich how are you doing
well
i'm doing great how are you i'm doing
better for talking to you i miss your
voice
you know man
i miss your voice and i think of you
every single time i get three dollar
checks for 22 jump street you know
that's what i think of my residuals we
always forgot that we got to do that
together yes the day we did voice work
what do we call what do we call it in
hollywood adr work is that what it is do
we do voice work
voiceover work i don't know either one
either one i think works i call it a
good hang time that's what i call it
yeah you know what i mean that's what i
call it
i haven't seen like like it
it felt like uh before covid we'd always
see each other for the big slick i know
i know been too long it has been well i
got to tell you
great to see mcgruber back it's great to
see him so walk me through the genesis
when did you first pitch mcgruber in in
a in a writer's room or come up with the
idea
i need to know the genesis of magruber
is basically what i'm saying okay so
jorma toconi
who was one of the lonely allen guys
uh he
had the original idea he just said this
is
a character he's macgyver's less
talented brother
and he pitched it to me and my buddy
john solomon and we kept thinking it
didn't sound like a good idea which uh
he kept pitching it though every week to
us to try to write it for that week's
show and we finally just to kind of get
him to shut up
we agreed to to do it and and uh
and thank god we did because
we're all
happy with uh we always like like uh
getting to do it and
it's pretty crazy to say i mean this is
back in 2007 yeah and uh i don't i don't
think anybody including us ever thought
that
it would still be alive in some form in
2021 so and here we are of course
because well it's timeless it's ageless
so uh who came up with the name mcgruber
the name was also mcgruber was
the
name of it from the get-go
in jerome's pitch
but he had i guess in fairness as we
he i think he was pitching it to us as a
live sketch on the show yes and then
once we finally agreed to write it we
all three of us came up with the idea of
that being more of a short film which
was in you know three three parts each
week well i think that's what makes it
uh you can't blow stuff up you can't you
can't get the big explosive finale you
know uh if you're doing it as a live
sketch that just doesn't it doesn't work
that way so i understand that
so you work shopping money i look back
now i had to look uh
somebody showed me
the very first one we ever did with
jeremy piven and i watch it and i go
like
how do we even how do they even let us
make a second
why it doesn't hold up just every step
of the way has been a big surprise you
know every every
every time you think it's like
the last uh you'll see it
and we're like a little you know we're a
television cockroach i guess okay so
who's in charge of pitching sam elliott
and showing him magruber who's in charge
of that to get him roped in will was
that you oh yeah i you know what that we
had a these amazing uh casting directors
and we've we would have never known to
go to sam elliot because we just would
have assumed oh familia would never do
it
he's exactly what you want sam elliott
to be too you meet him and you just have
in your head i think everyone has in
their head
what they think sam elliott will be like
and he's just
exactly that
plus plus
you know we all fell in love with the
guy and uh i wish i wish we
i wish i'd lived with them well i mean
you you had to at least get him to
record your outgoing message on your
phone right something like that
and i didn't ask him oh man that's an
opportunity right there one of the
greatest voices of all time sam elliott
oh yeah
oh my god and i tried to work on my
impersonation of him but i don't do as
good of one yarmouth taconi can do an
amazing one is that right
and you got lawrence fishburne locked in
man this is fun this is good stuff
brother
it's great and already you know
and and then you got uh kristen wiig
coming back and ryan phillippe it was
you know it's a
it was it was a
very fun summer it was like adult summer
camp mcgruber can be seen on peacock it
premieres today
uh only on this uh streaming service
where you can see the rich eisen show
we're on nbc sports on peacock every day
from 12 to 3 eastern time i'm sorry i
don't that's just that's just a
knee-jerk thing i didn't mean to use
your
show that you're here to promote to just
start promoting how you can see my show
which people are watching right now on
the service i don't quite understand
what i just did but i apologize well
the more popular peacock becomes uh the
more people will see both of our shows
mcgruber is raising all boats before
blowing it to smithereens is basically
what you're seeing or i would say that
rich eisen is raising
[Music]
thank you will i really appreciate that
here's what we need to do
here's what we need to do how can
mcgruber light the al davis torch in las
vegas nevada before raiders game how do
we do that
what do you think i haven't been yet i
haven't gotten to see i hear that the
the new stadium is just awesome it's i
have not been yet either you know
there's a club
there's a club that's in the end zone um
where people are just partying i don't
know if you're aware that that happens
in las vegas nevada
um but that's that's there but we should
get you to light the torch as mcgruber i
think that would be
something and
brockman how would that pitch to mike
mayako if i asked actually called mayak
and said i got will forte as magruber
he's a big fan of the raiders how about
that i'm guessing that mike had seen
macgyver so you would have to kind of
like that's true
that's true just be like well no it's
not actually macgyver we don't have
harry dean anderson or whatever his name
is richard richard same thing and it's
just like but it's like his not as
talented brother yeah but not his real
brother
no we couldn't go too deep we couldn't
get there yeah well maybe i should let
you do the pitching i don't know
and
well i i know for sure that the the that
would start by him saying who yeah
no he would think will forte was like a
cornerback that he missed when he went
to that colorado nebraska game right he
needs to grind scouting real forward she
needs to be grinding tape on will force
what's his 40 time
oh man that always makes me think
because you know you know i'm a raider
fan and
i always wanted to see somehow matt
forte get there to the raiders so i
could have a raiders jersey with forte
on it now that brings us to something we
constantly talk about here will is that
grown individuals
cannot wear a jersey
with somebody else's name on it but if
you wear a jersey with your own name on
it
that is doable is that what i'm saying
chris is that the is that
yeah like some way if we'll like if matt
forte did play for the raiders it would
be cool if bill got a right matt forte
jersey's right same last name that's
accepted that that you you would you'd
make the loophole that's not the
consensus or if i was if i was a tampa
bay fan and my name was will gronkowski
yes
well you'd change your name to that will
because you're a committed fan that's
how you are that's how deep he is i
guess maybe i would have to marry rob
ron kelsey and take his name that is
definitely that's also part of that
that's that's doable the option that's
doable
again i guess there are several ways to
do it we're just assuming it all takes
place in vegas you never know so well
this is fantastic um everything else
good with you life is good everything
else anything else that's going on in
your world you wanna
i'm recently married
uh we got a beautiful little daughter uh
zoe she's uh
ten months old 10 months and one day old
congrats and uh
and she's it's the best
it's the best i mean i i you always hear
what fatherhood is like and
it just is better better than you here
have you found yourself i understand why
because it's just like you just can't
you can't
explain it exactly you would give
everything
everything you'd give everything for
just the happiness of of that little
being that you have no control over
anymore which can be you know uh wait
wait till you know
uh they want an iphone 12 years from now
but it's okay look um
but but but um are you crying at
commercials now that you never used to
or
you having that sort of moment for you
well i was a big commercial crier anyway
but i think that that was like
but for sure
for sure there's another level of of uh
yes of
nostalgia and sympathy it's the way it
works will sweeps over me watching
commercials it's the way it works man i
i was applauding the end of elf the
other day with my children you know what
i mean and i used to watch it it's just
a whimsical movie and now i'm like yeah
that's the way santa sleigh takes off
you know i'm gonna i haven't seen one
yet i'm sure it's coming those bud
budweiser clydesdales
uh
those christmas commercials with cloud
sales i'm for sure gonna have some water
work there ah well congrats on the uh
the nuptials and i feel like i've missed
two registries uh wedding and baby so um
uh i i hope uh what will suffice is this
promotional appearance for mcgruber on
peacock right here on peacock
oh well this this is fantastic this is
perfect tell your wife that's what i've
gotten you for your uh wedding
she said she she loved that she'll
she'll be very happy with that well
congrats i'm so psyched i can't wait to
to stream all this man congrats on that
thank you very much
thank you good to hear your voice it's
been too long
right back at you will you take care of
yourself congrats again on this
you got it will fortes mcgruber he's the
writer ep and of course mcgruber himself
on peacock start streaming it today
mcgrouper
and then something would explode i know
susie and i sometimes we used to walk
through the house just saying that a
grouper
that's just like
whereas like macgyver
always got out of the jail of course
mcgrooper only gets injured
unfortunately that end disaster it was
untimely yeah
always hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here